die fliegerei wo immer schon ein
kindheitstraum von mir und wenn man das
verbinden kann dass man menschen hilft
zum beispiel die versorgung von
abgeschotteten gebieten oder die
unterstützung von feuerwehren bei
waldbränden beziehungsweise es bergan
von in bergnot geratenen wanderern
bergsteigern dann ist das für schöne
kombination und interessantes aufgaben
die zusammenarbeit bei uns in der
staffel funktioniert sehr gut wir sind
wie eine kleine familie so land daraus
resultierend weil man einfach alle
aufeinander angewiesen sind
es gibt kein auftrag denn was nur pilot
macht ist immer mindestens pilot technik
flugretter notarzt dabei und es waren
auch alle entscheidungen gemeinsam
getroffen
das heißt man muss auf jeden fall ein
teamplayer sein es müssen alle mittag
getroffenen entscheidung einverstanden
sein und nur so kann es funktionieren
ich wollte immer schon pilot beim
bundesheer werden weil die fliegerei im
generellen viel vielseitiges und auch
extremer als in der 2
man wird nie in die gegenden kommen in
dem militär unterwegs ist zum beispiel
zwischen baumwipfeln in sehr geringen
höhen herumfliegen am großvenediger
200.000 meter landen oder mitternacht
spezialeinheiten oder spezialtruppen auf
häuserdächern absetzen
die karriere des militärpiloten hat
nicht damit auf dass man jetzt
erscheinenden händen hält oder einfach
nur einsatz belohnt wird sondern man
kann sich viel zeit vielfältig
weiterentwickeln
man kann zum beispiel sich als
fluglehrer weiterentwickeln wenn man und
offizier ist oder eben wie ich es
gemacht habe auf die militärakademie zu
gehen um in weiterer folge gegen staffel
genannt zu werden oder weitere
führungspositionen zu erreichen
herzliche fitness ist bei uns als
militärpiloten extrem wichtig wir werden
jedes jahr im heeresspital auf herz und
nieren durchgecheckt und auch in
sportlicher hinsicht überprüft
deswegen ist es eines jeden piloten
eigener verantwortung sich körperlich
fit zu halten
wir haben jede menge möglichkeiten das
auch zu tun zwischen den flügen oder
auch an tagen an denen nicht geflogen
wird
es gibt die möglichkeit laufen zu gehen
oder ins fitnessstudio zu gehen oder
schwimmen zu gehen und ich glaube nicht
dass es einen anderen beruf geht an dem
man dienstzeit sport machen kann
ich habe mich entschieden helikopter
pilot zu werden weil fliegen einfach ist
und ich einen beruf haben wollte der
spaß macht und gleichzeitig
herausfordernd ist
sein bisheriges highlight war eine
internationale übung in portugal an der
mehrere nationen europas teilgenommen
haben und bei der ich an einem tag für
eine mission es mischen commander
verantwortlich war für den einsatz von
über 20 luftfahrzeugen darunter jets
kampfhubschrauber und transport
mich begeistert am beruf
hubschrauberpilot besonders dass man
nicht an die infrastruktur eines
flugplatzes gebunden ist sondern auch
eine landung inmitten eines waldes in
der lichtung machen kann um das leute
abzuholen oder taucher über der donau
absetzen kann oder auf einem berg landen
um dort bergsteiger einsteigen zu lassen
das spricht nicht besonders an
ich persönlich hätte es mir nicht
leisten können eine qualitativ dermaßen
hochwertige und kompakte ausbildung mit
zum militärpiloten am österreichischen
bundesheer zivil zu bezahlen
das bundesheer übernimmt die
ausbildungskosten und man bekommt als
militärpiloten anwärter vom ersten tag
der ausbildung an ein gutes gehalt
gezeigt